[Music]
welcome to New York City the crown jewel
of the real estate market everybody
wants a piece and now thanks to
blockchain technology that may very well
be possible this thirty-six point five
million dollar development is being
sliced into digital shares or tokenized
as it's called so that investors around
the world can own as much or as little
as they can afford we have the typical
bank financing on this project with a
conventional Bank and this loan matures
in January we decided to take a right
turn and tokenize the debt here on the
property a construction is 95% complete
we're starting to get inspections in the
next week or so we have a bank deadline
on us where we have to sell a certain
amount of units or repay the entire loan
by a certain date if constructions been
delayed if the market turns if
competition pops up and we're not going
to be able to hit that deadline what do
you do so by tokenizing the debt it
gives everyone breathing room to sell at
a normal pace with the market instead of
against it the people behind this
offering reside across the East River in
that other borough here the blockchain
startup fluidity has teamed up with
broker dealer firm propellor to generate
tokens by crafting smart contracts and
in so doing they could be changing the
way we all do business in the future
when we started to look at the real
estate industry it's probably one of the
most inefficient industries that exists
currently you have a lot of middlemen a
lot of lawyers a lot of bankers and just
being able to create something that has
real impact on an industry like that I
think you're looking at significant
disruption but for a project determined
to eliminate middlemen there's a lot of
people involved motivator I'm a lawyer
facilitator strategy project manager
developer Cove honor I'm just the broker
I'm a fan an important party that is
absent in this equation is a bank there
will not be a bank involved the process
goes something like this
these guys create tokens on the
blockchain the tokens represent the
condo units debt and can be traded as
private securities if token holders sell
their shares the
purchaser can either preserve the tokens
on the blockchain or cash them out there
by dissolving these tokens altogether
this theoretically would produce more
liquidity to a notoriously illiquid
market that's a hard asset bag secured
loan we're taking private securities and
we're putting a digital wrapper around
them which makes it easier to track and
easier to transfer there's only four
assets you can own in the world stock a
bond or currency or commodity we think
every single one of them is gonna get
digitized tokenize the world and that's
already happening a UK company recently
tokenized this andy warhol now a hundred
people owned 31.5% of this 5.6 million
dollar painting and when it rises in
value the tokens will as well so is the
same thing happening with New York City
real estate literally 2530 million
people can own a piece of this at a
dollar a pop when has that ever been
possible technically it's still not
possible at least yet that is many
hurdles remain before this becomes a
democratizing force for the masses not
least of which is the fact that these
tokens are only available to accredited
investors keeping the barrier of entry
high open only to the rich but all of
this is very new and hasn't yet fully
impacted the system blockchain
innovations like this one clearly has
the potential to disrupt the way we do
business and even the way we define the
very things that we own you know if
there's another downturn and banks say
oh we have a hard time lending now okay
well I don't need you because I can
tokenize my my loan that I want to to
use to buy that condo there and that's
what I'm gonna do so now we don't need
banks anymore
that is what's crazy
[Music]
you
you